the Kings this guy can I had him in the
first first round of last game didn't I
didn't I
okay and now we're gonna do this and
we're gonna push we're gonna get out of
sneaky stuff and I'm gonna give me tempo
on the Queen with tonight here and then
pawn push okay I was gonna go out there
anyhow is that night gonna be a pain he
might be okay with the night going here
and I just back up my queen here that
dark square Bishop is dead this night
has to go somewhere else that Knights in
a pin that Queen out of there I'm gonna
take that I'm gonna take that one and
now what do you want to do oh I'm on it
with my knight
you're gonna resign no why would they
resign hang on over here right here
anything anything anything anything
checks right here more checks push push
I'm dropping that pawn push move bishop
on push
where is that mean no stalemate time
uptime uptime no that's mate back to
tournament 500 Wolfman is there
oh man Wolfman is on the scene the one
guy you do not want to see in any
tournament is the Wolfman actually
there's more than just one guy more than
just one guy
there's Wolfman I think there's a guy
named the black ninja you don't want to
you do not want to meet that guy in a
dark alley either no you don't okay back
up
oh I should just push or something let's
hit that clean hit the Queen get to d3
take my knight I want to get to d3 oh I
just dropped my knight crap oh no no no
come on
please let it work out please let it
work out is it working out it's not
really working out it is not really
working out is it no it's not over here
trickiness hang on
sneak attack is not really working I
don't even know what that move does
that's me that was a helpmate back to
Turman oh just what I need
don't blink do not blink if you're
watching these if you blink you could
miss a mate or drop your queen oh man
that was the only square the King could
have run away - are they being sneaky
come on granola bar what's the matter
with you what is the matter with you I
have enough to worry about oh I got the
bishop I have enough to worry about oh
why didn't I don't really mean to do
that I thought the King had to recapture
mmm can I hang out of that pond I think
I can I think I can I think I can let's
just grab here connected past pawn
Knight wants to reposition he's an
animal he is an animal open that up chop
just take here now let's stop that okay
King position is the last no I want my
king to get in position I'll take with
my king blockade the king is a block
hater he's a fighter he is a fighter
stop it that rook is being a giant pain
stop it what did I do to deserve this
get over here pig on the seventh now
they're gonna be fearful aren't they are
they gonna be fearful what is my King
doing but somebody tell me that please
okay my King's gonna have to babysit
upon now push this guy the rook is ready
to play here ah where's my time 12
seconds
what am i doing over here this is not
working you know how I planned
how'd you plan it how did you plan it
what was the plan what was that plan can
somebody tell me what was that plan all
along
tricky Knights was the plan
riki nights tricky nights dead night
over here over here over here over here
run pond your past and your fast this
guy's flying did I win I wandered down a
time Oh twenty twelve twelve eleven
round 100 whoa is this a quick resigner
guy he's got negative 22 oh man maybe he
hasn't I double the points there's a
fifteen second rule I might get a quick
win this is how much time is left
yes that's exactly what I needed 20 20
that's the boost I needed Stalberg is
this guy gonna stall is he gonna be a
Staller yo no no no no add two friends
I'm okay with that I thought it was like
a quick resign button I hit free
thinking free thinking alright whoa that
was a back-to-back quick resign errs
that's what everybody wants to see
everybody wants to see a back-to-back
quick resigner okay I should have done
this first shouldn't I have let's try it
now oh that's a pin and now d5 d5 break
stuff open let's do this this is trouble
big trouble
difficult pin to deal with on that night
if Knight takes I shouldn't take with my
queen because I'd get mated I'll take
here and keep this pin keep that pin
that can be broken with Knight beat
three though you could take him that's
alright I want to get to see for now see
for hit this Queen the Queen's gonna
play here I guess
yes she is yes she is and there she goes
okay
that Bishop is a pain he is definitely a
pain that Bishop is it he
oh man I could play here now I could
definitely play here I'm on the bishop
be tricky what am I even doing there
okay I'm grabbing upon 20 I could grab
this again rook takes Bishop that's not
really working I'm on the I'm on the
rook they missed it oh oh they're gonna
resign resign time 13 seconds 12 seconds
eleven ten o'clock burner no no fry no
no fry in action hang on the bishop
might have snuck in there or something
they could have done a pre move thirty
seven thirty twenty rack for no that's
let's do that now let's do this I don't
can't make up my mind is this guy can
even move he is moving clean gambit
clean gambit it's supposed to be plural
and all the grammar freaks on my case
now it's Queens its Queens alright here
we go this is not the most ambitious is
it okay here we go support that night
support your beasts mean I don't
understand these terms you're thrown
around here support your beast what does
that even mean what does that mean I
don't have answers to any of these
questions dark squares dark squares is
where I want to be dark squares don't
play 2g4 please don't do it oh I insist
I insist no the Queen's gonna come back
to g4 don't let her do that no you need
to get out of there Queen I want to mean
get out of there let's try this again Oh
bishop move hang on
sneak attack it's a sneak attack
fifteen seconds 14 13 I shouldn't have
done that I didn't need to do that why
did I do that oh man they don't have any
time
anything Oh anything but that
okay there have any time it's gonna be
okay right
no time back to tournament fifty one
forty two twenty nine twenty to twenty
minutes remaining chess Network
I got a play against chess Network this
guy is a beast right here he's an animal
this guy look at him look at this guy
chess network okay
gotta be very careful with this guy he
chose those fishing poles and stuff he
throws those fishing poles and stuff
okay give me some space can I have some
space here this product could be taken
like a million times and now I can't
let's go majority in here with the
lights grab bishop oh that was almost
Adobe Flash what does that mean
explained up Adobe Flash would you okay
this rook wants to be right here and my
king wants to be where my king I don't
know what I want to do this guy's flying
why is he so fast the trade Queens get a
pig everybody loves a pig pig pigs alert
oh man this is dangerous this is very
dangerous very dangerous they've got a
pig now counter Pig threat what counter
pig threat yeah oh oh oh oh oh they got
pigs everywhere what does that even mean
what does that even mean oh man oh man
I'm hurting I'm hurt and I'm really hurt
and I'm really hurting oh man Oh 14
seconds I gotta win this I gotta win
this gotta win this
um punt push check anything where's the
no no Nate to thread or something
where's the matin to I throw some checks
in how much time the clock tick anything
their time is down oh man oh man
that was too tough 6750 for David Blaine
mode engaged
okay Oh LightSquared Bishop Soph okay
I'm right with that I am all right with
that one over here over here uh-oh I
grabbed that pawn push get that Bishop
out of there and then take here all the
bishops dead no it's not
can I get that night can I sneak in here
pawn push am i trapped get that night
out of there he needs to go okay let's
do this
no okay I could do that I'm on f7 f7 I
got the Queen I got that Queen Bishop
lock I could take it they resigned back
to term in 85 85 72 45 16 minutes
remaining c5 and now what Queen c7 I got
a sneak one of these in I'd it just
doesn't feel right if I don't get one of
these in
we get one of these in I get that pom
pushing again this is working out this
is a good it's a good thing to run
forward with when you have that pin
problems that mates maids maids maids
check oh where does that mate I want to
take that fish up take it with the bish
up it's matin to take it with the bish
of main two or three yes bishop asked a
block or its main deflection no okay
I'll be a friend
I forgot I keep clicking the wrong thing
105 72 double the debt double the cube
double the cube okay I'm pointing right
at f7 right at f7 and now I'm not I'm
biting on a rock east six is the rock if
you're wondering g6 is the rock there
goes the light square bishop clean over
in this direction pawn push I still want
to do okay it's open stuff up my queen
doesn't belong here she belongs on h4
did I do that too soon all right let's
try this again
let's try it again okay pawn push I got
to go here if I do if I went to h3
there's g4 to take here get my knight
involved my knight wants to be involved
as the knight gonna go here oh I'm glad
I did that the my Queen might have been
trapped if I didn't do that I don't
support my knight I feel like I want to
take here I want to keep my tricky night
around I need my Knight wants to be on
that five took me forever to figure that
out but I want to be on f5 f5 incoming
is gonna be brutal okay now where does
that mean where is that me support my
knight it's gonna go there I thought
night there would have been good my
queen is close to trapped I could do
this my queen could play here and I'm
threatening the rook threatening the
rook with me and also this and like rook
takes pawn or something defend that my
queen gonna be trapped
I'm on the Brooke Meghan - oh I'm glad
that worked out back to tournament I was
getting really really close right there
125 90 7563 14 minutes and change
collabs c5 c5 13 minutes and changed
okay well I got to stop going with this
setup I mean it's okay but for the
bullet I want to go with something maybe
more open do this sneak my knight in
there give up a pawn I could get my dark
side Bishop doing something pawn push
pawn storm over here I have control over
this square it might be pawn push and if
they get that pawn kick that night away
and then sneak my knight in here my
knight right here is gonna be a really
really he's gonna be a monster really
really what what are you trying to say
again what are you trying to say exactly
okay my queen is recapturing I want to
get in alright let's do this let's go
with this break I really want to get an
H 5 g 4 but it's just not happening
I'm on the Queen I'm on the clean that's
up I'm up a piece here stay right here
put pressure on that pond I should
probably just take that pond let's take
them now I shouldn't have taken them
okay let's come here the knight should
have played there maybe let's back up
pawn push over here my bishop is very
very valuable right here on e5 let's get
these pawns going my bishops are doing
really really well to support every
advance I'm okay with giving this up no
no let's just hit this Knight I should
have done that I know the bishop could
take but I thought I would give up the
exchange on favorable terms but not
really over here where is the mean where
is it the rook really can't move okay
and now let's just push
Bishop here Bishop here take the pawn
it's a mating three or something right
now the rook is there to defend maybe
I'll give a check give a check I want to
get to g3 and okay I got to g3 back
determinate that was me 145 130 85 11
minutes and change 145 130 85 where is
the Wolfman
oh I didn't mean to do that let's try
this Bishop b2 and c4 c4 is how I wanted
to crack at that black centre let's
break this pin first though take with
the pot I want the G file can I do
something with the G file please my
bishop is doing well to converge on that
point and get this advance in I should
just take in that pun I can still take
that pawn should I take that pawn I'm
gonna take that pawn I'm take them and
actually I'm gonna give up no okay
my bishops gonna be hit and my bishop
has to come back to block okay now to do
that I want to keep things closed in the
center I have a feeling up that's not
gonna happen d4 looks pretty appealing
yep yeah to get castled very soon get my
knight here queenside castle my bishops
in a good spot 22 seconds 20 19 18 oh
man 15 seconds remaining they're not
going to move is there some glitch and
my opponent really did move and what no
I didn't okay this is not gonna end it's
just not gonna end I can do this my
naked block my knight is there to block
and everything is cozy bishop check has
probably been there for a while back to
tournament 165 150 10 minute warning
amazing Oy amazing
okay sneak attack
watch out for the sneak attack Bishop g7
connect these Knights okay let's try
this one right here is like pong gonna
be targeted it might be can I get that
fish up I'm gonna take that dark square
Bishop pawn push pawn push light squares
where you at give me the light squares
I should probably defend a 6 B 6 under
fire Queen c7 I'm gonna weasel around I
am going to take here I think it's okay
it's probably not okay oh no this is
dangerous this is very dangerous now
very dangerous is working out somehow it
might be working now I want to get rid
of that tricky Knight tricky Knight
everywhere
mate thread I'm on that pawn as well 25
seconds remaining I'm defending against
this as well there's probably something
really bad there I think I could throw
this check in and a check here check
here and now I could get the Queen's off
15 seconds remaining
get out of there Knight you got to go
defend upon give a check discover tricks
discover tricks watch out for the
discovered tricks mmm let's give a check
time burners time burners time burners
time burners past pon another pass pawn
another pass pawn push them push them
again I could have taken that rook they
resigned back to tournament 185 148 that
was a big win
that was my nearest competitor oh that
got scary I had to play King to where I
had to play King where
King - what square was that okay let's
take here stay focused now I've got a
queen queen threat take that pawn and
then the queen is dead take the pawn and
the queen is dead queen is dead even if
you don't take the pawn oh cashing in
hang on hang on no tricks no tricks no
tricks avoid all the tricks let's just
take care in Castle mates right hang on
one two and then three
coming up one two three punch back to
term at 2:05 seven minutes remaining
seven and change 205 148 the Hitman
actually 168 is in second now let's try
this let's get that night out let's
organize some quick attack quick attack
and once again can i Oh Mouse slip I Oh
a mouse slip back-to-back mouse slips
back-to-back mouse lips okay let's just
take here we're gonna have the Queen's
off the board no we're not light squares
light squares where are you at are they
gonna give me the light squares
it's just Castle before the bishop plays
here with check night here if Bishop
here so I shouldn't do that
let's just open this up actually I'm
gonna push here I don't want this Square
to be made use of so I get night check
if pawn push I get the light square
Bishop working and I think right here is
an extremely active
square for my queen whoa I'm gonna go
here or something Queen here and then
Knight here I should have done that
different Queen here next right here
where is that me check discovered tricks
okay I get this the very least I get
that and a mate threat right here
there's probably like Bishop takes pawn
or something that's me
back to tournament 225 five minutes
remaining 528 225 again another big one
d4 okay let's try this no fishing poles
no fishing poles I shouldn't have done
that
why did I do that why didn't abstract my
C pond let's try this again let's try
that again
let's reroute let's reroute I'm gonna
take this I'm gonna take that one and
okay they're gonna resolve the tension
in the center pod pusher Knight is right
here and this is getting nuts because of
tricky stuff over here avoid the tricks
clean right here clean trade I'm okay
with I'm okay with this Queen trade
right rook back it up Pass pawn good
versus bad bishop let's get this pawn as
soon as possible
am I getting it as soon as possible not
really
can I do this safely it's gonna be scary
very scary pawn push King position King
position why am I not getting the King
position check and then here it's not
really working let's come back night
let's come here and now let's get these
pawns going I'm on that and this I have
this square cupboard and I'm on that
pond twice there's a check it's my king
getting mated not really not really I
could give a check where are those time
burners I've slipping me back up I'm not
getting made it anyway
I could still grab this let me grab this
actually can I get some time burners oh
I got that rook or the bishop where are
those time burners time burners got the
rooks off time time time oh that was
miss plate I think it's just working out
there down on time back to tournament
245 186 another big win
245 186 to 45 remaining chess husky is
on the scene right here he's on the
scene all right can I sneak in please I
really do just wanna get one fishing
pole and I'll be happy one fishing pole
please I please get one fishing pole in
there
I just dropped a pond but they didn't
take it oh man that happens that will
get the best of everybody the best of
everybody you see goes you start to
believe your opponent that's what I
really meant to say you start to just
believe your opponent you're like I
can't really take that safely can I at
this pond he's tough to defend he can't
be defended let's just get rid of a
tricky night I'll for a queen exchange
next right here right here cleans out
for they're gonna see it it's open the
position up these guys are dead pieces
for as long as that pond is right there
look on the second pig's night takes
here nope now I can Victory Lane oh
they're on my rook cut throw into check
though and then take the bishop don't
take here first and then take here and
then just give a check clean trade
actually I could have just taken the
Queen their take with the pawn push my
pawn give a check give a checker push
the night away get that night out of
there get him out of there get him out
of there
I want the Queen make sure you get that
pond whatever you do just make sure you
get that pond now come over here and
over there
swing over here and do that no matter
what take this pawn no stalemates no
stalemates whatever you do do not give
stalemate check check check
where are the checks they resigned back
to tournament 265 206 less than 40
minutes remaining this game is most
likely not gonna finish most likely not
gonna finish so what is the plan if it's
not going to finish here it's coming all
the way back I'm gonna take that night I
really put pressure on that I just
fainted
that's a fork I might have to notify my
way to victory Oh No
sneak attack sneak attack it's a queen
trapped she's not trapped she's not
trapped can I get the Queen's off the
board I might have to notify my way Nona
Frey where are you at where are you at
Nona Frey oh that was a pre move that
was missed Oh first place I actually
came back miraculously I got the piece
back but they called it that was never
gonna finish first place confetti boom
I'll take it good games 265 206 195 198
therefore a third right there all right